>> TUCKER DIDN'T SKIP TOWN
WITHOUT LEAVING SOMETHING AT
HOME.
>> BIGGEST THREAT OF FREEDOM OF
EXPRESSION IS NOT THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT.
IT IS POWERFUL CORPORATIONS.
PARTICULARLY TECH CORPORATIONS.
THEY CAN FIRE YOU FOR SPEAKING
YOUR MIND.
THEY CAN CENSURE HOW ONLINE.
DENNIS FOUNDED -- YOUTUBE IS
RESTRICTED HIS VIDEOS FROM BEING
CONSERVATIVE.
THEY'RE NOT GIVING LIBERAL
VIDEOS SAME TREATMENT.
THAT LAWSUIT IS ONGOING.
DENNIS THANK YOU FOR COMING ON.
WE'VE BEEN FOLLOWING YOUR SUIT.
WHY IS THIS IMPORTANT BEYOND THE
SUIT ITSELF?
>> THE INTERNET IS LARGELY
CONTROLLED IN TERMS OF
INFORMATION BY GOOGLE WHICH ALSO
USES AND RUNS YOUTUBE.
IF THEY DON'T ALLOW A FREE FLOW
OF INFORMATION, IT WOULD BE AS
IF THEY CAN ANALOGY YOUR
AIRPORTS THAT ONLY PEOPLE ON THE
LEFT CAN FLY AIRPLANES CAN BE
PASSENGERS ON AIRPLANES.
THAT WOULD BE EQUIVALENT.
THAT IS WHAT IS HAPPENING.
OUR LAWSUIT IS SO MUCH BIGGER
THAN US.
WE HAVE 600 MILLION VIEWS LAST
YEAR.
THAT'S PROBABLY WHY YOUTUBE IS
NOT A BIG FAN OF OURS.
WE HAVE FOUR PULITZER SURPRISE
WINNERS.
THEY ARE VERY EFFECT.
THEY PRESENT A SIDE OF LIFE THAT
IS NEVER HEARD OR ALMOST NEVER
HEARD ON OUR CAMPUSES.
THEY HAVE DECIDED THEY WILL PUT
IN THIS CASE, 40 OF OUR 300
VIDEOS ON THE RESTRICTED LIST.
MEANING, IT JOINS PORNOGRAPHY
AND VIOLENCE BEING RESTRICTED.
FOR EXAMPLE WE HAD A VIDEO BY
VICTOR DIVERS HENSON WHO IS
OPPOSITE OF FLAMETHROWER.
HE IS AS EVEN TEMPERED PROFESSOR
EXIST IN THE WORLD.
HE GAVE A THOUGHT, WHY DID WE
FIGHT IN KOREA.
THAT WAS ON THE RESTRICT--
RESTRICTED LIST.
THAT'S ON THE RESTRICTED LIST.
>> ARE YOU CONVINCED AFTER GOING
THROUGH THIS LONG PROSS AND
DIGGING INTO THE SUIT THAT
GOOGLE MOTIVES ARE IDEOLOGICAL.
>> THERE'S NO OTHER
POSSIBILITIES.
WE HAVE VIDEOS ON THE SAME
SUBJECT.
HERE'S AN AMAZING PROOF THAT IS
RECENT.
NOT SOMETHING THAT COULD HAVE
TOLD YOU THE LAST TIME I WAS ON
YOUR SHOW PIP DEBATED A MAN FROM
LEFT AT A SYNAGOGUE IN SAN
FRANCISCO.
THAT WAS PENT ON THE INTERNET.
THEY HAVE PUT THAT ON THE
RESTRICTED LIST.
A DEBATE IN A SYNAGOGUE KNOWN
FOR PORNOGRAPHY AND VIOLENCE.
APPARENTLY THEY FEEL THAT I DID
BETTER THAN MAN ON THE LEFT.
THEY PUT THAT ON THE RESTRICTED
LIST.
IT'S TRANSPARENTLY IDEOLOGICAL.